hey gang the new ay card game is
available at rug garbage.com right now
do you want to get your loved one the
perfect gift this year that might not
arrive by Christmas cuz we can guarantee
that these probably definitely won't
show up on time we got 50 new questions
to prove whether your family or friends
are absolute trash pick them up at rug
garbage.com
wo do it welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if you're favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is R you garbage Christmas
Spectacular I'm your host H Foley coming
at you on a beautiful cheery seasonal
day out back here at hoodies in the new
edition she went to to bed early uh-huh
if you know what I mean I'm not sure I
do she's Hammer drunk shout out to it
somebody decided to put Henny in the
eggnog it was a wild Choice wild choice
we have eggnog here and someone made it
with Hennessy it's crazy my co-host is
coming at you from across the table
Merry Christmas my friend Merry
Christmas buddy they say there's not a
real Santa Claus but man I tell you what
I'm sitting next to him right now baby
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in first off
happy Holidays baby we love you shout
out to the [__] Army of garbage
I hope you're all somewhere half a
sixpack deep you got your heaters you're
fighting with your mom whatever it is we
[__] love you shout out to you uh
make sure you R you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are TR
cooking uh then obviously the greatest
website of all time www.patreon.com it's
a goddamn Christmas miracle over there
if you catch my drift
and also we love you and also www.ru
garbage.com you get your tickets to our
gosh darn biggest show of our careers
Town Hall New York City it's about 1500
people get them tickets come out and see
us and also you can pick up the second
edition of the ru garbage card game you
ain't lying while supplies last yes pick
them up scoop them up I just want to
reiterate uh what Kippy said gang we
can't thank you enough for everything
this year we love you so much we're
hoping you're having a fantastic holid
today and also how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good the
Elf on the Shelf give it
up for T-Bone McGruff ands Toby McMullen
everybody what up boys what up T-Bone oh
I'm having a great day we're in here
it's Christmas time I've been snooping
doing a little peeking trying to figure
out what's what oh I've got my razor
blade out resealing the resealing the
preses I'm up to my old tricks what time
you got to be back at the workshop there
big
guy can't tell if you're wrapping
presents or making
cookies oh I got that eggnog in me you
better watch out hey that right now Jes
Christ this thing's going to go off the
rails quick oh Big Dog's got nog on the
brain I like an eggnog I'll tell you
that it's just egg beers and
Henny it's not even actually eggnog I
don't know if I've ever had Hennessy
before this shit's goddamn delicious
okay I mean this is finally know what
Nas was talking about it's [__]
fantastic
boys Merry Christmas it is it's the
[__] holiday season baby holiday
season um I don't want to start this off
on a negative note every time you say
that we end up getting in a fight with
somebody don't do what don't okay what
is it I'm it it was a real pain in the
ass what everything nothing works
anymore uhhuh the deliveries to this to
that [__] he's got two things he was
mad at the weather earlier he's like
nothing wor Works no more he was like
got R's
raining that's a hard feeling so we got
the goddamn holiday extravagan that we
have to get to I know not your
[__] E or Scrooge gripes over here
hey man it's not the holidays without a
fulley ruin in The Vibes very true I'm
over here we're talking joy and cheer
and sharing sharing love with people and
you're upset about the rain man if the
folies know how to do one thing it's
ruined every event you've ever gone to
it's ruined Christmas sure you're ruined
Christmas and then an hour later we're
you know I love you makeig hugs and
kisses make with the presents toots you
know what I'm saying you got to play
ball you were uh shaking some hands and
kissing some babies this holiday season
pressing the flesh with some uh some
holiday festivities it sure was I went
to uh I had my family's Christmas party
uh which we have to run a hall out a
Polish Hall I going to say how was the
firehouse this time of year it's a
Polish catering hall in Bridesburg
Philadelphia oh I can smell that
underneath the paint factory smells like
onions uh I got the open bar package you
got the chafing dishes there's a lot
there like a hundred of us so um it's
great it's awesome good time what are
you throwing down what's in the chafing
dishes this one I wanted to bring up it
was we it was good but it was tur like
turkey and gravy which was a little
strange I feel for Christmas what it was
pen pen pasta turkey wait hold on P pen
and red sauce pen and red sauce God damn
man the Irish are trash it was we put
[__] a side of pasta with anything
man buddy it's so good when those when
those big catering halls make it it's so
good it's so good it was pen it was it's
always burnt ones it's it's never
spaghetti it's always pen or R Tony I'm
spaghetti I'm not an [__] what are
you talking I make a couple of bucks
we're getting a penny you know what I
mean that's rich guys that's rich guy
pasta the Irish like a pen with a real
hard end oh yeah slapped onto the side
of a PL there could be a piece of
meatloaf on there they don't give a [__]
yeah dude I was eating penet and turkey
and gravy and stuffing it's crazy it was
nuts that's great it was nuts it was
great though the turkey it ended up
being great it all works man the rolls
they had at the end of the the rolls
they had at the end of the table like a
salad bowl yeah they're unbelievable
they have like a sheen on them like a
shine it was great it was great shout
out to the you know middle of the road
mediocre [__] catering all food Kippy
was kneed deep in in uh the salad with
the with the cereal bowl full of ranch
right there just yep let's go uh so
black olives and croutons we did that
that's a that's a salad right there get
you in a h get in a given mood right
there I don't like seeing a salad like
Buffet off a salad bar with just
hardboiled eggs and a mountain of cheese
some real wet ham
cubes those cubes are the grossest thing
I've ever seen in my life they look like
dog food I sprinkle was in like like
Lucky Charms marshmallows love it I
can't just the sodium sweating out of it
nitrates um so I had I had uh right so
that was early ER that was like 5 to9
the family Christmas party right right
and that used to be a big thing we'd all
go out afterwards like all the C you
know all the cousins everybody in their
like 20s and 30s and stuff sure what all
go out but now everybody's older
everybody's got kids so it's like that
rattle that that wound down you don't
want to do nothing I know but then so
I'm in the city I'm with it I'm about
that yeah I want to go to bed at 9: I
get it I'm right there with you bud but
I was I had a couple in me I I had a
hotel in uh in Philadelphia for the
night and uh my buddies some one of my
Philly friends was having a holiday
party with like you know a nice classy
Suare in south philadel at his at his
house in South Philadelphia okay we they
had a keg of pilsner not that [__]
light [__] yeah I can't tell if you're
if if you sp this or not no it was not
classy in South Philadelphia usually
don't walk on the same street they're
Italian Italian so it's you know it's
it's the it's polished a little bit you
know what I mean they don't have [__]
you're still in a row home yeah that
doesn't mean it can't be classy I'm not
saying it can't I was just trying to
paint a picture that's what you
insinuated that was the only thing you
said to deit to discredit the nice party
does it have those narrow stairs that go
straight up you feel like you're an
Edgar Allen Post House I don't think so
was a normal uh the valet situation or
were they just stealing cars they stole
my car there was a guy in a red t-shirt
he seemed like a straight shooter
somebody brought a catalytic converter
to the white elephant um no it was I'm
not classy but it was like a like a ugly
sweater it wasn't like a it wasn't a c
it was you know he has like a wine uh
he's do I know this gentleman yeah okay
ant big ant oh okay yeah yeah yeah so
it's a it's a redo nice house redo a
those got nice the whole
thing good cash he's throwing around
he's got maybe you know he's got about
[__] I don't know 120 bottles of wine
and a thing he's like these are there
he's like oh what you know very you know
now I got a picture I was trying to get
a picture it wasn't classy but you know
nicer well and
so I get there and I only know him my
boy Pat's there cuz it's like one
removed it's not my immediate crew I'm
boys with him and it's his crew right so
I'm the outsider I come a little later
too everybody's already there any bozos
any homies
uh one guy KN one guy knew the show yeah
one guy he's like you do that show with
that fat ass don't he Stak you're
probably walking in with a scarf and
sunglasses on I come in wreaking of
heaters re I'm I'm a heavy bike heaters
heaters in bed Penny dude well I hadn't
eaten in a long time right I ate early
at I ate about 5 it's now about 10:30 I
got I don't know 20 beers in me it's a
holiday season man so I go to those
Christmas burps must have been rocking
man
so I'm now I'm kind of hungry right and
I get there they have a they have a
decent spread their Italian they got
like you know the P the whatever but
that's all been kind of mowed over by
the time I get there you got to get
there quick for a saw I saw the remnants
of a of a Chick-fil-A nugget
[Laughter]
platter man I have one in my immediate
future dude there was three left night
I'm saying he's bit ants like you know
oh this bottle of wine is whatever and
I'm I'm just side die in that tray and
Nuggets but the and then there was a
soft pretzel tray like the pretzel
nugget tray the Philly Soft Pretzel
nugget tray which we've been well
documented how much I like them I was at
the other end of the table and this is
dude obviously I'm not trying to I'm a
married man there was a gaggle of of hot
broads at the at the place that were all
they were they were all at the counter
not eating but just like that was so
they were blocking the food man and I
was dude I was trying to well that's
what it gives you the freedom to just be
like hey when you move take tots get out
of my thing no there was still some fat
kid shame dude it they were too hot and
I I there was no way into that pretzel
tray just trying to run the pretzel
Gauntlet I felt like a linebacker trying
to break that line dude you broads live
here I was like making I was like bad I
was like throwing cans of a beer down
the stairs to cause a distraction you're
grabbing your boys yo tush push me
through these babes yeah quick someone
fall down the stairs and I get a handful
of pretzels pay a guy 10 bucks to fake a
heart attack and I could go I I would go
over and get one and stuff like that
like as I was going to get a beer or
whatever I was going to get one but
that's not at that point it's not that's
not you need I need to I want to sit
there and eat 25 of them I'm done doing
that and this year at the at the two uh
holiday things that I that I get to go
to that I'm lucky enough to go to with
my family I'm not [__] around what do
you mean you're not you didn't say not
doing I'm not picking I'm getting a
[__] plate of them of of the chicky
nugget that's yeah it's different your
family you can do whatever the obviously
we can do whatever the [__] we want know
our pieces not a couple of [__] South
Philly sevens walking around I got
[__] nacho cheese on my face who are
you yeah who do you know and I'm like
cool smoking here I'm [__] I came in
they were like I tried talking to one
kid for fat ass love it what dips did
they have did he have that the cinnamon
one I didn't see the C uh I did see the
cheese couldn't get my hands on dude at
one time I was I I did just grab a
handful like I called I called eyes with
one broad was like what are you doing we
talked about this when we did when we
did Timmy D show the Tim Dylan show we
talk we can't stress this enough if you
have access to a Chick-fil-A nugget tray
and a and a soft pretzel nugget tray
they have to be a part of your holiday
experience they are lights out also if
you do it unannounced if like
everybody's at that and you walk in with
the Chick-fil-A nugget tray like hiring
a stripper you're like [__] Santa
Claus dude that's amazing man cuz you
don't think about it until it's there oh
and you're like I'll do one dude they're
so [__] do yourself a favorite gang
it was great it was a [__] it was
good a lot of holiday cheer I hadn't
done a friends one in a long time you
know what I mean it was a good hang got
the knock the family it was great that
they were all the same day I was just
like Johnny holiday party I got no
holiday cheer I don't know what it is
it's cuz you're a Crogan yeah um also
felt good to yeah you're right zero push
bag just a man accepting his fate well
so far that he's complained about stairs
and the rain so it's like there's not a
lot to he doesn't have a big defense he
can I want to find my holiday cheer I'm
excited to go to uh I think it's at the
bottom of that [__]
eggnog Ryan diesel straighten me out um
I'm excited to go to midnight mass on
Christmas Eve I feel like that's where
I'm going to f find my could be yeah you
get the smell the [__] all the you
know the myr or whatever they're burning
in there I'm a micro do before I go
there you go yeah so I can really get
into it it's all Boomers with you I want
to see
Jesus Front Row Metallica you know what
you
know wearing a tuxedo t-shirt I'm
tripping balls I'm in the community line
and I'm dripping
balls uh yeah they do it nice at this
church we go to it's not our church
either we go to another church yeah that
was big on Christmas we always went to
another church we go to the Italian
church we used to go to the German
Church down there in Port Richmond the
Italians a little little tighter Nick
community over there um I just I just
button my shirt a couple of things they
don't know you know idiots you know what
did get me in the holiday cheer a little
bit that could help have you tipped uh
have you tipped the guys yet I wanted to
talk to you about that I tipped my
garage guys
yesterday man and I I handed them also
this is how trash I am I didn't do the
card I just did n they don't want justed
an envelope they don't want the card put
a C note in each one for the boys I I
just wrote their their last names on it
[__] man I handed it to him I go
that's you know I go that's for all you
they all had one individually he turned
around D he he went in and opened it
which I respect he popped in a little
Hut opened it that's why I always like
to hang out with the with the with the
server saw what I was [__] you know I
was throwing some heat around came out
thank you I'm going to get in the comp
thank you so much much thank and I went
oh yeah like that is that's the holiday
season baby that guy turned around
looked at his boys and said I gave us 10
bucks this piece of [__] come back fart
in his car next time he comes
back I'm telling you it helps it helps
um so I do so I do have just one Supra I
don't have a team really good to us what
are you thinking I don't know you said
you you whack them off a little bit
already I whack them off all the time
for bet you do
scum uh for anything he does 20 here 40
here 50 here hundo here whatever I'm
thinking four four that's the number
four is the number yep yeah four is the
number what I'm think I'm giving my
super a strong handshake and a look in
the eye thank you don't do it dude no
I'm going to look him up of course yeah
you got to you got to even if they suck
you got to cuz they can make you cuz
then they yeah make it worse M make it
worse I'm telling you it ain't great you
got you got greas them um there you go
all right I'm telling you it really
helped I pulled out headed into headed
into those [__] parties just [__]
tip him I stopped to get you stopped to
get your present as well and on the way
out they were like they were like hey do
you want a tip we're trying to you know
get money whatever for this thing who
was it St judees I always do St Jud it
was St judees or something something it
was child Danny Thomas's outfit it was
for a child and uh it was like you can
do one five or 10 I said I'll do 10 and
she was like oh my God that is so kind
kind of you I said I would have done
five if I knew I could have got away
with it D bro we're going to head into a
recession I'm on a podcast what are you
talking about you flicker a dime keep it
sweetheart I take that back I had a
slight touch of the holiday cheer
yesterday picking up your gift how about
that because I really think I nailed it
this year okay I really really do
awesome awesome well all the years that
that you know the last couple of years
couple of missteps well the Vegas Oz are
plus 2500 on you blowing it really they
are they are ke talking about fume shout
out to fume OG fume gang coping with
life by using a habit is great as long
as the Habit is a good one obviously
fume gives that nasty hand-to mouth
habit a serious upgrade by taking away
the stinky the Bad and the dangerous
Parts which you know there's a lot of
but it lets you keep the Habit itself
that's right yeah let you keep the Habit
itself fume is an Innovative a
war-winning device instead of vapor fume
uses flavored Air instead of electronics
fume is completely natural instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors yeah you get the point it's an
allaround way better choice for dealing
with the stressors of Life they've sent
them to us they're fantastic it takes
the edge off it clears your head a
little bit it's easy peasy they even
have a brand new device for you to try
the fume salano it takes the original
and levels it up with a premium Walnut
barrel and a smooth coating on the black
mouthpiece uh start the holidays off
right with good habit by going to
tume.to today fume is giving uh
listeners of areu garbage 10% off when
you use the code garbage to help make
starting the good habit that much easier
one more time uh F fumees giving ay
listeners 10% off when they use the code
garbage to help make starting the good
habit that much easier do it Kippy I got
two words for you Adam and Eve I got two
more bot plug let's go talking stocking
stuffers ladies and gentlemen gang you
know we love Adam and were over here you
know we love getting weird what a better
time to do it than the holiday season to
drop some hints to spice it up a little
bit whether you're whe whether you're
with your significant other or [__]
whether you're by yourself even more of
a reason to reach out have a goddamn
happy holiday listen it gets dark early
and cold well you're not outside you're
inside spice it up and Notch uh if
you're looking to keep of them cies if
if you're looking to keep that naughty
status just between you and Santa Claus
don't P don't padic Adam and Eve has
totally discreet shopping they got it
all the whips the chains the butt plugs
the Fleshlight the dildos man you got to
love some Adam and Eve copy go Adam and
Eve has been making people feel good oh
feeling real freaky naughty for over 50
years so you know you can trust them
don't wait better sex is just a click
away take 50% off one item and free
shipping with free Rush processing so
you you got that hard on it's going to
get there soon there you go just go to
Adam andeve.com select any one item use
the code garbage at checkout this is an
exclusive offer for our listeners be
sure to use code garbage to get your
discount 100% free shipping and Rush
processing that's Adam and eve.com promo
code garbage Adam and eve.com code
garbage do it do it let's do some
[__] presents [__] Straight Out The
Boys Around The Bu it's [__]
Christmas morning Luke's over there in
his goddamn pajamas yeah so let's
digging through digging through the
French toast sticks let's start with the
youngest let's get oh there
puki grab the chair come on sit in the
middle Skippy meoo watch your phone
there big
fell is his mic hot yeah yes sir wow you
had that ready huh we got a production
team over here sit your skinny ass down
oh [__] died up there we go get in there
all right gang if you don't know most of
you do new guy Luke new guy Luke luky
patuki how cool guy Luke ly patuki um
let me get he's on air Talent now you
should be sitting on my lap should be I
don't hate
that get over here you get a little
squeezing in I got that Henny In Me Do
you have do you have his present I was
supposed to bring it of course I got his
present so you got a present from uh
from me and Uncle Kippy all right you
got one deposit in your bank account for
being honest
do the boys were taking care of uh
little jelly in a month club if you
catch my drift talk about butter at a
month club a little bit of ghee
what do we got here
wow slightly
ripped as it looks like it was in the
mud dude it was [__] raining outside
what the hell the hell did you do with
those presents
man the broad wrapped out up that looks
like a good WRA job and then you stepped
on it it's a nice wrap job yeah here it
looks like roller blades got to go that
way I would go that way um actually I
would go that way um yeah this is uh
this is from uh Uncle Kippy and me wow
okay okay thank you guys I think you're
going to enjoy it do you have any idea
none
whoa yeah hit him with it how you
doing PS5 for the P snap the big gift
right off the Jump that's how we do it
at the fley house I ain't waiting and
looking behind no goddamn couch there
you go kid join yourself yeah and got a
little something for you too wow clear
out some of this yeah yeah yeah thank
you guys you're welcome buddy I know you
said you wanted to get back into your
video games a little bit and it has the
dis changer so you can use the uh the
the [__]
Ry so you can use the uh your old games
you can watch your movies on there too I
hear the Blu-rays yeah you can spank it
watch your videos thank you very much
guys ran D wrapped my presents for me so
that might be for King
fingers cross the Kippy one
yeah oh [__]
Hess yo the boys are buzzing now thank
you Toby you got paddles on the back so
you can really School these new oh my
God Toby you had no idea how much
restraint it took me not to screw you
over what not buy the PS5 because he's
like he's like you're definitely getting
the the the PS5 right I'm like we're
definitely getting he's like cuz I'm
going to get him a remote control and
man
I went back and forth that's you should
have done that you should have got him
an Xbox dude why did you not run that by
me I would have I would have [__]
cosigned that
immediately you [__] piece of
[__] all right you Merry Christmas kid
mer want your gifts now yeah you give us
Merry Merry Christmas all right I'll do
uh Toby first okay sick yeah I'm down
all right all right this is great this
is the holiday cheer oh new this guy's
not on air town he's tripping expensive
Electronics from Japan that's that's
that's American Christmas baby so what's
the what's B is not included wait that's
for me just bring it over here all right
how many are in here Toby what one it's
one but it's badass It's like got
remappable buttons you can really I'm
not going to expose myself to how big a
nerd I am but if you play Call of Duty
that's what you want so he's got one
good he's got one remote and then and
then one in the Box yeah you might want
to do this one over there but I know you
know Toby's restarting his life getting
things together getting the home in
order and man it's a month in rehab it
sounds like who said he was restarting
his life getting his life in order we
got you two tickets to Sloan kering
rehab it's either that or Tupperware oh
[__] I your Curry Poots and
B there you go there you go I tell you
what they're good we use yours every
every day at the house that's all right
yeah kiy loves the one I got for him too
it's the full kit damn this is thank you
bro this is sick cook all the crack you
want chef chef buo Arby out there oh man
I'm really going to look at these pots
while I'm opening
uberit what do you got kiddo all right
we'll do uh you uncle Hank first all
right okay buddy oh man this is really
bringing me joy I love you guys love you
guys
to here we
go oh [__] that's all right gives you
something to do gives me something to do
I can do it with my
nephew so for the folks out there that
don't know I'm a pretty big Star Wars
nerd and this is my favorite ship it's
the
laat uh troop
trans Virgin Atlantic and you know I
like my Legos thank you buddy that's
very sweet of love you man did you know
that was his favorite yeah I had run it
by him kind of yeah that's awesome I
love got the guys to play with got every
got some moving doors and stuff yeah
that's pretty sweet look at that right
there Legos nice thanks buddy I love it
now now the holidays would not be the
holidays but a little bit of a Kur
fuffle okay so for kippy's presid I am
drawing My Line in the Sand of the war I
don't what does that mean I will fight
you
Luke drawing your Line in the Sand of
the
war this makes me real nervous dude and
um we you been working way too hard and
I'm way too tired for
this you wrapped the bag wrap the bag
make it look a little bigger all right
all right I'll give it to you black tea
the black tea for the one the
the for the one and only heir of the
black te
uh what kingdom mad happy that's your
buddy thank you very much very
thoughtful and we we needed troops along
the border thank you very much
those winners are tough in Black
tville buddy thank you so much love you
guys love you buddy thank you very much
go happy holiday go up to your room and
play your uh Playstation if you want to
have a couple of your buddies come over
you can but they got to be out of here
by eight the rest of the family is going
to be here and if you're drinking no
driving anything and don't wake up your
aunt toty up there all right and pick up
these uh the wrapping paper before you
go up there all right and make sure you
salt the walkway so T-Bone's next so you
got to have just give T-Bone what one's
T-Bones uh that little the little one on
top ly grab that little one on
top give it to t-bone that's from uh
that's from me and me and the big dog
that's for me that's for me that's for
Mom and Dad yeah oh okay all right a
little joint present huh we did join
present this year smart yeah yeah yeah
all right what also increases the money
spent which opens up to better you know
what I mean of course just open it up
it's not a pair of loafers okay Jesus
Lord all right here we we go oh [__] VR
headset yeah the new that's the three
too that's the new one just dropped just
saw a commercial for that yesterday
actually oh I'm going to put it on my
cat freak him
out don't jump off a bridge oh man the
boobs I'm going to look at at this thing
shout out to do a lot with it yeah this
is sick thank you guys so much you're
welcome buddy Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas oh oh yes
Merry Christmas just what I need to be
more of a dork okay can I fill up my
eggnog sure Bud uh uh I figured I know
it's not it's definitely not your sup
but it's like you are a tech guy and
it's it's you know this whole show could
be in VR in two years who knows I've
thought about it we got to get you
figuring it out you can't get off Mike
it's just me then I know I was realiz I
went to make this guy's over back at the
four I mean uncle Hank is really be he's
really uh in his element you've had four
you've had four dozen eggs so
far it's true we suck down a whole
carton it's Chris protein heavy diet
this guy all right let me I'm going to
grab my stuff okay that was nice good
job yeah you getting after it huh little
nip nothing wrong with it huh sure
cheers to you and yours
folks thank you buddy is that okay yeah
that's for uh that's for uncle Hank
there it's uh P qu oh that Henny should
have got me a bottle of this man this
guy really gets gift blindness when the
booze is out open the gift what are you
doing the all right it
easy do you have any clue what it is no
this is from you Toby it is and I think
Ryan D Ryan D wrapped all my presents
for me I think it's a box within a box
that's my bad it's okay buddy thank you
and this is
mine that's mine as well double double
box he gets two yours is bigger his is a
combo this is heavy
too
God damn
it about to read off your
address please don't oh yeah Luke please
be very mindful of that we'll be right
back after this Helix ad ladies and
gentlemen I don't need it now I think
should have had it 10 minutes ago I
blame
diesel oh great another box how'd you
get this
Russia what is it a sniper rifle holy
[__] you got me a [__]
lightsaber let's [__] go come on come
on come on that thing is he easy with
that come on dog damn dude this thing's
sick yeah bro and you can well show's
over good night everybody and you can
change the color on it so it's blue when
you're in a good mood and then it's red
when you go Sith mode I'm I'm clipping
this thing on my [__] belt rolling
around come on yeah
TBO
t-o yeah woo I'm All Star Wars up thanks
boys that looks official it's pretty
sick I'm not going to front man my cat
does have very dark side Tendencies it
needs to be taught a
lesson that's [__] sick yeah it makes
all the sounds and stuff it's tight oh
I'm rolling around with this yeah [__]
yeah I might take the thing off and just
keep it attached to my belt do whatever
you want bro [__] pops off you know what
I mean sure just my Henny and My
lightsaber that's what you need
drinking jeez great job great job great
job T-Bone I love you thank you what one
do I open first this one yes it's it's a
combo all right I like combos all right
so all right I
that box was already open I had to make
sure it was the right thing gotcha so
first
up this is this is all stuff inspired by
your your your new foray into any Town
USA okay all right so up first up first
we got okay for the for for the booze
bag in your life sure I respect it for
the booze bag you this is the one
drinking Henny and eggs right now I know
I think it slides out maybe Henny and
eggs is all right I don't think it
does uh do you have that knife fly
where's the throat slitter
Luke he's putting my weapon together oh
we I got it [__] could pop off at any
time yeah thank you
ly so a couple of nice very nice Crystal
whiskey glazes very nice little holiday
booze for you huh that's nice love that
going to Christ e Christmas Eve we have
a I always drink whiskey with the boys I
know you said that in the car and I was
like nailed it oh that was pre uh you
already had it yeah yeah yeah love that
okay and this goes this goes with those
glasses now you might be thinking to
yourself what's that an expensive bottle
of whiskey you'd be wrong okay it's a
huge Ice
Cube case a
Henny oh that's sick love that dude so
it's the uh the thing that shoots the
ball for the dog it's an automatic ball
tosser so you can sit on your back porch
while hzi plays with himself while yep
that's a good gift come on he got it for
you to throw the ball to
me B's got to get his steps in that's
awesome D thank you so much 40
feet by the way I saw a video of that
backyard not too shabby my backyard yeah
why' you see a video of that the bird
showed me I gu guess they they were
they're talking real nice I told you you
got a real nice spot over real nice
piece of property thank you very much
Tbone that's [__] awesome great job
T-Bone home run baby thank you um all
right I'll go I'll give Foy next right
we're clear of I'm all so it's just me
and you me and you I I mean we are on
the precipice of the very
first legitimate exchange sure no no
one's blown it so
far um there's a handful of things in
here okay I went classy with the painter
[Music]
St so there's uh a few practical things
and
one you know whatever thing one thing I
think you you know with a with an idea
behind it is it a cloak to go with my
lightsaber it's not now I feel like an
[__] I'm the only one that didn't get
you [__] Ah that's nice all right so
oo what yeah you said what I know what I
said I'm a good liar a nice I got him a
Polo hoodie DXL went in air yesterday
DXL four 4XL perfect you know why she go
she walked in she goes who you shopping
for I went thank God still got a couple
pounds to play with
she's I said wo you were over at my
store at the XL not that one I went to
the one in Cherry Hill oh but I is
Regina still working she still got that
tight little a on her uh I go uh she
goes who you shopping for I said A buddy
of mine she goes do you know what size
he is I go I think a 4X she goes does he
shop with us I go he does she goes give
me his phone number pulled up everything
you've ever bought there she goes yeah
he's a 5660 or whatever the [__] he's a
40,000 by 50,000 hey those XL dildos
weren't mine um so I got you the a black
peac coat wow that's not an everyday
thing but you know a dinner whatever
something a little you need a little
more versatility in your wardrobe now
that you're slimming down for the homies
there I I had mentioned that I was going
to get somebody a a coat and I'm talking
about I want a PECO gi's like don't get
somebody a coat it's not a good idea you
sneaky little bastard thank you of
course and then that is a
uh oh is it a watch it is it is
uh oh that's nice it is a replica like a
remake of every of the watch that every
Soldier to Vietnam had no [__] yeah I
was awesome was going to spring for the
orig but they were in real bad shape so
and they they had they they a reissue
this year man I'm a [__] army uniform
away from walking around the wall Mak
people salute
me that's beautiful Kippy thank you of
course nice coat I got to try this on
yeah go for it hang on you boys Scamp a
little
bit the thought behind the watch too was
it might have been one your dad had had
at the time which I'll probably just
make you start crying I don't know why I
brought that up two years he had that
hunk of metal up his
ass your sit there crying um I hope it
fits it should
fit a it's a little big
huh I got my Star Wars cloak you guys
it's a Christmas miracle we found
clothes that are too big for they said
it couldn't be done and I put my mind to
it I'll take it over to the lady and get
a tailored yeah you could return and
just go get a new size as well no I like
it yeah you can get the same one just a
new size it's beautiful thank you buddy
of course buddy and I went shorter they
had like the long ones but I don't know
if you could pull that off n d I'm
caught in the middle you be looking like
Town Hall walking around that's a lot of
curtain Stuck In The Middle With
food great job pal thank you buddy happy
holidays I love you K let's talk about
bespoke post shout out to bespoke post
let's talk about the Box are awesome mhm
let's talk about when you give a gift in
the holiday season it's a oneand done
yep not with bespoke post sign somebody
up for the Box awesome they get cool
stuff every single month GI the keeps
giving grilling stuff outdoor stuff
stuff for the home bar grooming things
high quality all done with nice Partners
small businesses a lot of it made in
America what are you going to do it's
been great I've been getting them like
honestly probably for 2 years now it's
fantastic every month it shows up I got
my cool little thing my cocktail thing
camping stuff clothes outdoor stuff
indoor stuff bar more knives than John
Wick uh to get started all you do is
take the quick quiz at box ofawesome.com
their expert their experts will match
you with a box you'd love the most take
the quiz for yourself or take it with
your family and friends uh in mind for
personal gift advice it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month at any time
or cancel each box is valued around 70
bucks but you pay only a fraction of
that price baby plus each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses 90%
of everything that comes from your box
of awesome is from a small upand
cominging brand get 20% off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box
ofawesome.com enter the code garbage or
check out that's box ofawesome.com code
garbage for 20% off your first box box
ofawesome.com code garbage do it let's
go can't much talk about co-pilot shout
out to co-pilot baby again keeping
yourself motivated as tough as everybody
knows especially when it comes to
Fitness that's why you need co-pilot
co-pilot is your personalized Fitness
solution combining the accountability of
a human expert with the flexibility of
Technology your virtual coach customizes
guided workouts to fit your goals your
schedule your injuries and your time
yeah it's fantastic I've been using it
on the road trying to just trying to
saave off the the holiday thing that's
going to get you you know what I mean
positive reinforcement trying to keep a
pound or two off trying to stay at figh
and wait and not go full on on big guy
you know uh not you just myself
personally uh this isn't some AI telling
you to do more curls There's an actual
trainer in your phone giving you expert
advice telling a workout routine to you
if something doesn't feel right or
you're ready for the next step just tell
them and they'll change it up for you uh
no access to weights or or only have 10
minutes before you need to catch the bu
work out anytime anywhere make Fitness
the seamless part of your life I was
doing it in a hotel room no big deal uh
we'd love for you to follow our lead and
get fit and feel fabulous go to co-pilot
give co-pilot a try find out why it was
listed as Forbes to top rated personal
trainer app of 2023 head to mycoop
pilot.com garbage and get a 14-day free
trial and 20% off your first month of
personalized Fitness with your own
personal trainer if you sign up before
February 1st 2024 that's myop pilot.com
garbage to get a free 14-day trial and
20% off your first month sign up for the
new year gang step in there right yeah
since I'm already up I'm going to get
yours sure and I got to be honest with I
see one
thing like gives me you should have hid
that part I
think okay I don't believe
that nice say
[Music]
[Laughter]
there Jesus Christ how the hell is this
getting
home I think I know what this is and
it's a home
run so you're going to open
this and then I'm going to tell you
gentlemen
a tale of anger Vengeance
deceit yes it's [__] awesome thank
you it's a what do you get the guy that
hold on a second before you open that I
swung in a Miss swing in a Miss with the
with the bass guitar which is sitting
over there sure slight swing in the Miss
with the cruise slight so what do you
get the guy who has everything remember
remember last year when you were like uh
you know you you know me what I'm you
know think about what I'm doing what you
know what all that
stuff and the bird came up with this no
[__] I've been talking about this too
have you I was talking about it last
night with my friends but no like also
like I thought I said it in the car me
and Luke were talking about it you're a
homeowner now uh-huh so pop it open for
the flatbread freak what do you get the
flatbread freak that's the question you
ask what do you get the [__]
flatbread freak it's his own God oh
Jesus Christ the oi multifuel
Pizza Oven Hai Machi G with pizza
tray I'm GNA be making scrambies with
that thing and I got a I got that's
amazing I got a bag of uh a bag of wood
at the house for you too okay but
they're pellets I don't know if you want
to use that sure dude buddy [__]
amazing job thank you so much that's
[__] fantastic that's your spatula I
got you the 12 in it's ready in 15
minutes and it takes about 90 seconds to
do a pizza sounds like already cracked
it
open those parmesan stains were already
on there I got it as is it was the floor
model um this is sick dude so you can
make so if you're having people over the
family over you can make multiple
different pies with different things on
that's great I I literally just said to
Luke we just had this conversation I was
like dude I I want to get one so bad uh
I think the idea of like having your
boys over just people over just you know
constantly throwing in pies let's do a
sausage let's do it this [__]
fantastic buddy thank you so much you're
welcome pal it's multifuel you can use
coal or you can use wood and you can
kill the world's biggest fly use this in
a
bedroom that's [__] fantastic buddy
thank you so much there you go
finally what I think we we we we batted
the cycle right I think everybody killed
it that's not bad we
did look can you give me a
hand don't you fire that thing up get a
couple of [__] Z
going in the air oh
God all right that was [__] awesome
great job everybody luky great job um
Luke is my lightsaber
ready
okay so here's the
deal I'm gonna tell
you this worked out
perfectly as of yesterday I had nothing
uh-huh and I'm like [__] what am I going
to do she hits me with the pizza up
that's crazy was we've yeah I'm like
you're a [__] goddamn genius
brilliant perfect brilliant so now over
the last three
weeks I the [__] was that it was your
lightsaber
ooh I thought I felt something I feel a
somewhere somewhere on the premise so
here's the deal I'm going to tell you a
quick story um
the reason why I'm so like frazzled
about the the holidays and this and that
and these are these are micro problems I
realize that but
[__] I have been dealing with a
logistical nightmare with [__] Best
Buy all right your original
gift which I yeah this is better you
yeah you have been upset at Best Buy
four weeks at this point yeah I thought
it was for Toby's gift or I thought it
was for Luke's gift I'm a good liar as
well uh-huh well it was about Luke's
gift okay all right so your original
gift I was going to get you a massage
chair for
here that's all right take the pizza
oven back I can buy pizza dude I got
Uber Eats in The Dominoes app wow all
right they're expensive though I'm well
aware that do you think that thing
wasn't cheap either that's no massage I
don't know but that's no massage chair
sure massage chairs are like four grand
my credit car is jammed up right now
because the [__] Best Buy policy dude
I don't want to brutal so let me take
you back a couple of weeks so are they
taking it back cuz if not it would look
nice in here it's already it was already
cancelled but we can get one for we can
get one for here um yeah I know but then
also I was like you know he's talking
about that but he's talking about
getting one at his house and stuff like
that's when she said Pizza of it I'm
like that's [__] it that's something
that he loves something that he likes to
do he's got the new house she showed me
the video of the backyard I'm like you
can put that right there you're out
there [__] doing pizzas you [__]
delicious oh my God she'll think it's
delivery she won't know so ad hen's
catching up to me Jesus
Christ all right so about three weeks
ago I order the massage chair and I
order Luke's PlayStation 5 both from
Best Buy all right the reason that I
purchased them was because it said the
delivery date would be this delivery
date would be this okay cool plenty of
time no worries gonna have [__] Ryan
D here he's gonna [__] they're going
to get it upstairs he's going to set it
up we're going to put a big box around
it a big bow whatever bada boom bada
bing couple days later the PlayStation 5
it looks like it's getting jammed up all
of a sudden it's not in stock it's not
going to be here on time
I call I'm getting the runaround like
like legitimately getting the [__]
runaround like nobody knows anything Jo
they're waiting for a verification of
some I'm like lady you charged my credit
card already what and you don't like
that you don't like what verific do you
need right but up
until uh Friday I was extremely civil
all
[Music]
right so I don't believe leave that for
one second I'm being serious so cuz I
cuz the bird was right next to me and
she doesn't like that [__] she she yells
at me if I if I get testy with customer
service
people
so um a few days whatever you know this
happens you know they're stringing me
along and all this stuff and nobody
knows what's going on so I cancel that
okay I cancel the PlayStation 5 she buys
or no this this is what happened I can I
ask you one question yeah I imagine that
you're being civil was you doing stuff
like okay okay so you're telling me
there's nothing you just speaking
through your te that doesn't make any
sense just squeezing your phone there's
a little bit of that sure I've seen you
but if you played back to recordings you
wouldn't be able to tell this guy's a
psychopath so long as it was transcribed
yeah all right so so here's here's what
happened so I say to the bird now I'm a
[__] dirt bag all right this one's
not going to be here until the
20th I've been asking a couple of
questions about PlayStation 5es so I
tell the bird I say listen get one
somewhere else and we'll just let this
show up and then Uncle Hank's got a
PlayStation 5
sure so she does that she she she orders
it from Target okay um
but against my wishes cancels the one at
Best Buy all right which Best Buy
instead of freeing the charge they
charge me twice for the chair that's the
best way I can describe it let's say it
was $2,000 for for both items on the
first purchase instead of taking the
$2,000 away and then charging me a th000
they just bang me out for another 1,500
for for for the chair double dip you
let's yeah and leaves and just leaves it
on there all right and like it it'll go
away in 10 days or whatever the card is
jammed up
like and I don't want to pay anything on
it because I don't trust that always
something with you I because I don't
trust that you know if I pay over what
my limit is if if if it's going to all
go back on there I'm starting to spiral
now the chair says everything is cool
okay chair's gonna be here Friday all
right I get Ryan diesel be there at 7:00
7 to 7 is the window the bars moving on
the follow of the thing whatever you
know the the order details but in the
email there's another bar that says view
most recent status and that says
scheduling has not been made appointment
has not been made so I'm on the phone
with them okay and this is this is like
Wednesday I'm on the phone with them
she's on the phone with them we're going
back and forth we're [__] getting
into it she's exhausted [__] dealing
with this going back and forth back and
forth back and forth back all so much
stress all over an item relx you
crazy
so I mean I touched base with her on
Friday with with with her I say where we
at she's like I just spoke to somebody
over there it's going to be there
between 12: and 4: I'm like fantastic
he's got some dinner he's got to go to
perfect 4:00 comes and goes
nothing I jump on the phone all right I
call [__] this H we don't know yeah
it's it's just they just keep they don't
they're just it's just a script they're
just well they were waiting on the
verification and unfortunately and we
don't know and d d and I know they don't
know it's not them I understand they're
hardworking people they're not they're
not they're they're not
responsible then around 6
o'clock when's this Friday okay I get a
text from the bird she's like I have
this guy on the phone who seems like a a
little bit more legit than the you know
the bottom of the Run customer service
people I'm going to merge the call so
you can talk to him and figure it out
Jesus so they merge the call and anytime
you merge a call it's never good so I'm
[__] livid at this point I'm [__]
so pissed my cards jammed up I got
nothing for him I'm [__] pissed and
the PlayStation 2 still hasn't arrived
by the way from Target so I don't even
know if that's going to [__] show
up so they merged the call this guy real
you know real professional real cool hey
what's going I'm like listen man I've
been dealing with this for [__] two
weeks I just where's the where's the
chair tell me what's going on he's like
I have to call this other company that
deal that is the middleman between Best
Buy and and whoever delivers it for him
they called it the a bridge department
or something like that man I'm like I
got to call them and I'll call you back
I'm like no no dude I this don't you
hang up on me I that this such a [__]
I'm like no I'm not doing that you're
never going to [__] call me back they
never do I'll stay on the phone I'll
stay on the phone and he's like okay all
right calls the person the lady answers
the phone and the guy's like um hey how
are you this is so and so and uh you
know we have a situation here and uh I
just want to let you know this is a warm
a warm TR transfer a warm transfer
meaning that oh you're on the line I'm
on the line and she's like um wait a
minute is the customer on the line and
he's like yeah he's like you cannot do
that we're not a we're not a we're not a
customer facing forward facing forward-
facing entity we cannot have this
conversation with with with him on the
phone oh we're having this conversation
that's exactly what I
said you can't run anymore you cockroach
so I I'm I'm like why is that because
you're not going to I mean tell me where
tell me where the the piece of furniture
I just want to know where it is what's
going on you charge my car twice B she's
stonewalling me she's like sir we cannot
have this
conversation so I'm so I go over with
the guy I'm like what's my number I make
him repeat my number back I'm like
you're going to call me back right he's
like sir I'm going to call you back I'm
like yeah sure you're going to call me
back and I hang up and I'm sitting there
[__] well would you call you back no
exactly oh you're going to call me back
I wouldn't the chair yes you would have
what are we talking about tell
[__] so it turns out the chair was at a
warehouse in pascan but they wouldn't
let R they wouldn't let Ryan D go pick
it up I'm like I'll hire somebody to go
pick it up I wasn't going to pay him but
sure now you can't do that but it's
crazy because I found one at Bob's
Discount Furniture in the same goddamn
warehouse and they said that you could
pick it up but it stun so I didn't get
it for you anyway so I'm [__] furious
he's been waiting here all day I'm
waiting [__] here this that and other
thing and I understand it's the holidays
all that kind of stuff I know I'm being
a little over the top but this is 3
weeks of [__] just getting the
runaround from them all
right so I hang up and I'm sitting there
and about 30 seconds later I get a text
from my better half saying hey the phone
never disconnected I have them both on
the line right now cuz she merged the
call with me and
she was still on it she was still on
with them she's like do you want to hear
what they're saying and I'm like baby
that's why I love you man let's do it
what' they say trash in your fat
toothless face your girl's outside of a
bob discounts Warehouse in a flower
tra she's got Seth Green on a computer
man I dude I never loved her more I was
like oh [__] and it was me and Diesel
sitting there and we're both just like
let's [__] go
so I put my so she transferred me I put
my phone on mute and they're going back
and forth real professional what
happened this Happ so what happened was
is that the verification which I still
don't know what the [__] that means
didn't come through it was on hold now
it's not on hold but the problem is is
that the delivery guys have already gone
home now that doesn't make any sense
because they're supposed to be
delivering up until like 7 or 8:00 all
right they they should still be able to
get it out to me this that and the other
thing and I go to Ryan I'm starting to
get matter and matter with this so just
what they're saying but they're not
they're not trashing me they're not
whatever they're they're they're they're
they're just doing their thing so I say
to Ryan D I'm like should I unmute this
and blow up this spot Jesus and he's
like do not do that do not [__] do
that you can't you're never going to get
the chair true don't do that I would
just if I was them and you did they
you're not wrong for doing it but they
still hold the power they could just
[__] they can charge your card four
more times three buttons or delete your
whole order or whatever so he's like do
not [__] do that and
then they start taking shots at me what'
they
say I heard you say there it's not
untrue yeah they did he said the guy was
like oh this guy's going to be really
upset or something like that or blah
blah blah and you know the scene at the
end of D Jango where Kristoff walz
shoots Leonardo Dicaprio and he turns
around to uh U Jamie Fox and he's like I
couldn't resist or whatever he says
Brian D's like don't do it man don't do
it and I'm like big dogs got to eat
[__] hit mute I'm like I heard
everything you [__] said this is
[__] [__] where's my [__]
chair [__] [__] [__] son of a
[__] [__] blah blah blah and
they just both go disconnect the call
boom and they're just [__] Gone In
The Wind in the Wind wi he never called
me back so where what is the status have
you got your money back or no have not
got my money back canceled the chair a
couple uh like 20 minutes later soon as
I hang up Ryan Diesel's like what the
[__] is wrong with you you [__] did
they could have helped you out or
something didn't realize the bird was
still on the
line This is the slowest news day for
your whole crew you guys are all just
sitting around Eaves dropping on other
people
I get a call from her 12 seconds L what
the [__] is wrong with you you never
going to get the [__]
chair Jesus but I took that as a huge
Victory I got this we got that I got him
we got him
T-Bone you're
drunk we
did and that's all that matters oh that
oh let me make a call to the other
department you know they're [__]
blowing smoke up your ass and like we
got to see it we we we got them uhhuh
handled it like a true Jedi Hank
yeah don't make me come down with my
light'll force be with you all right we
got to wrap it up gang it's been a
holiday [__] spectacular love my
watch love my coat Love My lightsaber
love my Legos thank you boys yeah buddy
you got all you got new toys you got
some fresh fits you got some I got new
toys I got new clothes and a new found
love oh God for Hennessy spice up the
holidays with a little Hennessy fight
your in-laws with
Hennessy and happy holidays to whatever
you're celebrating out there enjoy
yourself get some pigs in a blanket in
you yeah be safe fight with your mom
whatever you do do it whatever is
tradition for you you're in it baby
someone here on this listening to this
show has a Christmas tradition or a
holiday tradition where they go out and
they just really shoot a gun in the air
sure just into the whatever just into
the void I like that that's what we
should get each other next year guns
okay I mean we're going to have to move
but sure [__] be can't be walking
around riding dirty Merry Christmas gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace peace